puis après la fin des apl la fin de la
taxe d'habitation blessés l'âge et andré
gattolin des mici mais si au bout d'un
moment andré garros
au bout d'un moment je suis désolé mais
c'est comme ça dans la vraie vie entre
la moitié de coronado raser le coco je
peux lui parler je peux pas vous à bas
des marches pas d'opinion toutes les
semaines oui o'bready majorité kurde
dans le pays
oui mais excusez moi si on veut
s'éloigner jeudi au sujet de sénateurs
communistes et lieu en seine-saint-denis
parce qu'on est con gardien et on reste
sur la même ligne
si on ne change pas de ligne toutes les
semaines andré gattolin les annonces qui
ont été faites c'est ça qui a kiffé le
résultat d'aujourd'hui aux élections
sénatoriales et rien d'autre on attire
un petit peu des mobilisations de rue et
le vote de la moitié de la russie je
crois qu'on doit être non non je veux
dire faut être un petit peu raisonnable
c'est à dire qu'à un moment quand on dit
que le pays est endetté et contient plus
nos engagements qu'il faut le réduire
et je rappelle à mon collègue d'allier
quand même
je peux m'exprimer mais votre moment je
rappelle quand même que le candidat qui
étaient ici de la première de la droite
et de la gauche proposée dans son
programme initial
le double de coupe dans les
collectivités territoriales donc il faut
bien dire un moment oui à peu près il a
changé en cours de route on maison du
compte que c'était pas plus